howard stern had some thoughts about
people who don't get vaccinated in fact
he was on his show he started by
laughing and mocking
the uh a few conservative radio hosts
who were
said they didn't want to get vaccinated
and then they died of coronavirus and
that's happened a few times
and howard stern thinks that's hilarious
he had a lot of fun with that i mean
these are people you know just normal
people who died they had families and
kids howard stern thought it was
hilarious and then he starts talking
about in general people who don't want
to get vaccinated and this this was his
uh his thoughts about it
i'll tell you what as far as i remember
when i went to school you had to get a
measles vaccine you had to get a mom's
vaccine you had to get there was a ton
of them you got polio
in order to go to school you have to
have certain vaccines when are we going
to stop putting up with the idiots in
this country and just say you now it's
mandatory to get vaccinated
their freedom i want my freedom to live
i want to get out of the house already i
want to go next door and play chess
you remember when howard stern was
you know counter culture
rebellious edgy
and this is what he is now this is this
is the
problem stick around too long on the
scene he's in what is he in his 70s now
should have retired years ago
maggie's cranky old man complaining
because he wants to leave his house and
play chess and take
pictures go ahead and do that no one's
stopping you howard go ahead leave leave
your house who said you can't you're
vaccinated
whoever you want to play chess with i'm
assuming i mean you i'm assuming you
don't comport with the unclean
unvaccinated type so they're vaccinated
put on your mat put on five masks
go to your friend's house and play chess
if you want to have him wear five masks
too
no one's stopping you from doing that
this this rich old guy
hiding in his home
trembling in fear because people who are
far away from him are not vaccinated
pose no threat to him whatsoever
but this this uh statement of f your
freedoms
howard stern's not the first one to say
that
we've been hearing that more and more
that is a that is a very startling
development in a country
when you have people especially in
america it was built on this idea of
freedom
and we always thought
you know i've talked in the past about
what what is
as americans we say we're the united
states of america
what is it that unites us anymore how
are we one people or one country what
what unifying thing is there aside from
geography and even the geography isn't
very unifying anymore because we've
erased the borders so those are
indistinct as well so what is it aside
from the fact that we all basically live
in the same kind of region
of the globe uh what what holds us all
together
what do we have in common as americans
and i've been saying for years there's
really nothing
but the one answer that i've always
gotten from from people
is that uh well we all we all believe in
freedom that's what we have in common
now even if that was true i'm not sure
that it's enough to make a real country
a real people you know
but it's not true
it hasn't been true for a while and now
they're being open about it
they're saying f your freedom
f your freedom i want to feel safer
i will gladly trade your freedom for my
safety
and not even for my safety but for my
feeling of safety
because howard stern's safety is not at
all being jeopardized by any
unvaccinated person
living in his bubble in his rich
neighborhood where everybody is
vaccinated
so what he's saying and he's not the
only one
is
i will i'll take your freedom away
just so i can feel better
it's bad enough when we've got many
americans who feel that way and it's
been like that for for years
but now that they're saying it f your
freedom
that's a bad sign nothing good that we
don't go anywhere
you know there's nothing good comes from
that
there is no happy ending that begins
with f your freedoms
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated